el presidente ya hay bolsonaro
protagonizó un nuevo enfrentamiento con
la prensa esta vez directamente con un
reportero del sistema globo que le
preguntó sobre un escándalo que salpica
a su esposa michelle bolsonaro así
respondió el mandatario
la pregunta estaba relacionada con
depósitos hechos a la cuenta de la
primera dama por parte de fabricio
queirós un ex asesor de su hijo flavio y
quien se encuentra preso por presunta
malversación de fondos el diario 'o
globo' emitió un comunicado en el que
repudia la agresión del presidente
contra el periodista tan intimidación
muestra que yair bolsonaro desconoce el
deber de cualquier servidor público sin
importar su cargo de rendir cuentas a la
población en un hecho aparte
bolsonaro se burló de los periodistas
durante una rueda de prensa señalando
que los medios se ríen de sus historias
de cuando era un hombre atlético cuando
el cubit 19 infecta a gente tonta como
ustedes las posibilidades de sobrevivir
son mucho menores sólo saben hacer mal
usar la pluma para el mal en gran parte
lo deep box desde que llegó a la
presidencia la relación de jair
bolsonaro con la prensa brasileña no ha
sido
la mejor el mandatario siempre ha
acusado a los medios de propagar
desinformación principalmente en temas
relacionados con el brote de kobe 19 y
la emergencia por los incendios en el
amazonas cuya gestión es criticada a
nivel internacional